It's been nearly 13 months since Russia
invaded the sovereign nation of Ukraine.
Ukraine has been independent since 1991
and has presented
no threat whatsoever to Russia.
Russia launched
and has continued for over a year now.
A war of aggression and flagrant
violation of international law.
This is and remains
a Russian frontal assault
on the rules based international order
that has been in place for 80 years,
eight decades
since the end of World War Two
and the face of this act of aggression
in a war of conquest.
This group remains unified.
NATO's united.
The people of Ukraine are unyielding.
They are standing
steadfast in the face
of the Russian onslaught.
Russia remains isolated.
Their military stocks
are rapidly depleting.
The soldiers are demoralized, untrained,
unmotivated conscripts and convicts,
and their leadership is failing them.
Having already failed
in their strategic objectives.
Russia is increasingly relying
on other countries,
such as Iran and North Korea,
as the Secretary pointed out.
They are using Iranian drones
to continue to terrorize
Ukrainian civilians.
This relationship is built
on the cruel bonds of oppressing freedom,
subverting liberty,
and maintaining their tyranny.
Yet free
people will not return
to the shackles of tyranny.
Ukrainians remain defiant
still in their spines
and courage in their veins,
and they have the broad support
of the United States
and the international community.
The battle of park mode continues.
But Ukraine is fighting the valor
with robust defenses.
Ukraine has fixed
the Russian forces at that city,
and they're exacting
very heavy costs on the border group
and the Russian regular military.
Ukraine remains strong.
There are capable and trained Ukrainian
soldiers,
a strength strong in their combat units.
Their tanks,
infantry fighting vehicles
and armored vehicles
are only going to bolster the front line.
Ukrainian precision munitions continue
to target the logistics
and communications systems of Russia.
Lacking
effective small unit
leaders and absent the proper equipment.
This is a grinding attrition warfare
that Russia is trying to execute.
Wave after wave of Russian soldiers
are thrown into the chaos of war.
Absent
any sort of synchronized coordination
and direction,
Russia continues to pay severely
in terms of lives and military equipment
for its continued war of choice.
Right now
there is intense fighting in and around.
And the Russians are making small
tactical advances, but at great cost.
Elsewhere, the front line
remains relatively static
with significant exchanges of artillery,
but no significant maneuver gains
by either side.
Right now,
as you know,
there is a significant ongoing
effort to build up
the Ukrainian military
in terms of equipment, munitions
and training
in a variety of countries
in order to enable
Ukraine to defend itself.
The increased Ukrainian capability
will allow the Ukrainian leadership
to develop and execute
a variety of options in the future
to achieve their objectives
and bring this war
to a successful conclusion.
This is an act of brutal aggression
by President Putin
and the Russian military
with complete disregard for human life,
both civilian and military
The Russians are
wantonly killing civilians
in large attacks
on civilian infrastructure,
in densely populated urban areas,
severely undertrained
poorly led,
poorly equipped
Russian forces
are conducting mindless frontal attacks
and sacrificing hundreds per day.
The political
objectives that Putin intended to achieve
384 days ago
are obvious to the world,
and it should be obvious
to Putin that these objectives
are no longer achievable
by continuing this war.
And Putin can end this war,
and he can end it today,
and he needs to do so.
Free people are not easily conquered.
And the Ukrainian people are free.
And they will never give up
in their fight to stay free.
Two weeks ago,
the United States released
another security assistance package,
which included high Mars ammunition.
Artillery,
vehicle maintenance and vehicles.
The nine countries have pledged over
150 leopard tanks, for example.
This group
that met today is providing
air defense, artillery,
regular artillery, rocket, artillery,
armor, ammunition.
And that will be critical
to Ukraine's ability
to continue the fight
A broad mix of air
defense systems have been promised,
and they will protect the skies of Kiev
and the free cities of Ukraine.
Artillery and armor
are going to strengthen Ukraine lines
enable their forces
to synchronize fire and movement
for either offensive
or defensive operations.
Long range fires will challenge
Russia's ability to command and control,
protect and sustain their forces.
The Ukrainian soldiers
wear the blue
and yellow of the Ukrainian flag.
But the colors of 50 other nations
that met today
stand beside Ukraine
to support the principles
of the rules based international order.
A system in place to prevent aggression
and uphold the values of liberty
and sovereignty.
That system is what preserves the peace
and provides benefits
throughout the globe.
As President Biden,
Secretary Austin
and many others
to include
all the leaders of Europe
have said many times
that we will remain
committed for as long as it takes.
Thank you,
and I look forward to your questions.
Thank you, gentlemen.
First question, go to lead a Boulder
Associated Press. Thank you.
Um, Mr.
Secretary,
you said you spoke with your counterpart.
Can you give us a sense of
the Russian's reaction to the call?
Did they suggest to you
their defense that this was an accident
or intentional or that it never happened?
Can you just give us a better
readout of your call?
And, General Milley,
have you spoken
to your counterpart
or are you intending to do so?
And do you believe
after what you've seen
that this was intentional?
Is this considered an act of war?
Thanks for the question, Leader.
Leader,
I won't speak for Minister Shoigu,
nor will
I get into the details of our discussion.
I'll just reiterate that
the United States will fly and operate
wherever international law allows.
Now we take any potential for escalation
very seriously.
And that's why
I believe it's important
to keep the lines of communication open.
I think it's really key that
that we're able
to pick up the phone
and engage each other.
And I think that that will help to
prevent miscalculation.
Going forward.
So, Leader, thanks for the question
on the intentionality.
Don't know.
I do plan to talk to my counterpart,
General Gerasimov.
We have a scheduled call.
We'll see if that works out.
So was that intentional or not?
I don't know yet.
We know that
The Intercept was intentional.
the aggressive behavior was intentional.
We also know it was very unprofessional
and very unsafe.
The actual contact of the fixed wing
Russian fighter
with our UAV,
the physical contact of those two,
not sure yet. That remains to be seen.
But I can't
I can tell you
with certainty, though,
that we have absolute
evidence of the contact,
the intercepts etc.
and it's very aggressive.
You've heard
about the dumping of the fuel
and everything else.
We have video evidence of all that.
So there's there's no question
that that part of its intention
of the actual physical contact
of the aircraft that I'm not so sure.
So we'll have to figure that out,
that we're not
we're not positive of that yet.
As far as an act of war goes,
I'm not going to
I'm not going to go there.
Incidents happen and and clearly
we do not seek armed conflict with
with Russia.
And and I believe that
at this
point we should investigate this incident
and move on from there.
But we will continue to exercise
our rights in international airspace.